I have been dying for this car charger.
I got it off the TikTok shop.
It's link right here if you want one.
Now that I think about it,
I feel like this would be perfect for somebody who does
like, Uber or something,
cause it has a lightning port,
a USB C, and then it's got two open, uh,
ports where you can connect your own charger.
So I feel like this would be great for like, a, um,
an Uber driver,
cause I could put it kind of in the back,
and, you know,
they can offer this to their person.
However, as a mom of four kids,
that my phone always goes dead.
I cannot charge my phone
and my little external battery at the same time.
And then if my kids have a device,
cause we're going somewhere,
they can have theirs plugged into.
It also even has like,
a little voltage meter,
so it will tell you how much voltages it's using,
so it's not draining your car's battery.
This thing from the TikTok shop
is literally one of my favorite purchases.
If you want one,
the link is right here.
And I do make a small commission,
and I appreciate it.
Thank you. Bye.